ce genre de plaisanterie chez William
Leymergie c'est une baffe dans la gueule
non quelqu'un qui est encore plus
méchant que moi Stéphane Guillon
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
ça va mon style vous connaissez tout le
monde oui oui j'ai que des amis ah bon
avant de commencer j'aimerais dire à
communiquer à l'antenne ça t'ennuie pas
du tout
suite à l'étranglement d'un chroniqueur
de Télématin par William Leymergie
j'appelle tous les chroniqueurs du PAF à
manifester dimanche à la Bastille
stop au cou au bar aux injures
même quand nos papiers sont à chier
alors une semaine très positive que de
bonnes idées et on commence avec Marcel
Marceau star mondial Marcel Marsault
avait appris à Michael Jackson à bouger
son corps très doué Bambi mi met le nez
de Pinocchio avec son sexe
les enfants
une idée précoce toujours pressée
Sarkozy a rendu hommage au mime Marceau
avec 10 jours d'avance en me disant rien
pour la mort de Jacques Martin
la dernière idée d'Afflelou pour un
enterrement
la deuxième paire est gratuite
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
une belle idée maintenant le Mondial gay
de foot a démarré en Argentine sur cette
photo Thierry Henry lors de sa sélection
une idée de fayot mardi France 2
présenter une thématique Nicolas Sarkozy
20h le journal une demi-heure de Sarkozy
20h50 human bombe deux heures de Sarkozy
22h35 Faites entrer l'accusé et là
c'était le fils de Sarkozy
[Applaudissements]
une idée caritative Nikos Aliagas a
chanté à l'Olympia pour la lutte contre
le cancer faut vraiment soigner cette
maladie
[Rires]
une idée étonnante grâce à l'aide de
Sosie VSD nous dévoile l'intimité des
stars David Beckham au cabinet Mick
Jagger faisant sa lessive plus étonnante
Thierry Ardisson et Marc-Olivier Fogiel
sur le même cliché alors
Thierry
moi ce sont bien des sosies non mais on
s'est mis le plus loin possible oui
c'est vrai mais vous êtes pareils
pas vraiment ça fait partie de votre
légende vous le savez d'accord
une idée à creuser pour brésortefeu
puisque les sans-papiers se défenestrent
lors des contrôles de police nos
journées systématiquement au dernier
étage
ça pourrait s'appeler le décret Mike
Brant
[Applaudissements]
une idée risquée liberté pour un
pédophile dangereux grâce au bracelet
électronique donc si sa Bible dans une
maternelle c'est ou un portable ou un
pédophile faut réagir très vite
ce genre de plaisanterie chez William
Leymergie c'est une baffe dans la gueule
et on termine avec un grand bravo à
Laure Manaudou on pensait que pour elle
les victoires bah c'était du passé et
bien cette semaine elle décroche son
permis de conduire merci
[Applaudissements]
c'est un permis de conduire
enfin une image d'amour dans un monde de
brut deux éléphants du PS au temps du
bonheur
Ségolène couché sur le flanc à temps
l'arrivée de François à la semaine
prochaine et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu